[Music]
race car simulators help train race car
drivers off the track
they provide realistic visuals and
sensations
bumps jolts swerves whatever movement
you'd feel if you were sitting in the
driver's seat of a real race car
this race car simulator can be
programmed to produce a range of racing
scenarios and weather conditions it can
replicate any car
on any track
[Music]
first a computer guided laser cuts many
of the simulators parts from steel
sheets
after workers sand the rough areas a
machine reads the final shape with a
laser
to make sure the part meets
specifications
if a part requires bending it is done
with the press
this is one of the side brackets for the
driver's seat
the simulator's main structure is made
primarily of steel tubing
they saw the lengths required
then a computer guided mill drills holes
for the bolts that will later be used to
attach the simulator's components
once all the steel tubes are ready a
welder puts them in a jig to align them
correctly for assembly
[Music]
the structure's tubular parts are welded
together
then the worker adds the simulator's
sheet steel parts
and sprays the structure with industrial
grade paint
now they mount an audio speaker and
amplifier for the vibration system
motion controllers that move the
steering wheel and driver seat are also
added
[Music]
they install the power distribution
block
and a sub controller for each of the two
actuators
they install the cables required for the
simulator's components
and plug them into a usb hub then they
install the computer
and plug it into the usb hub as well
they cover the top of the structure with
the textured aluminum panel
they bolt the bottom of the actuators to
the structure and plug them into the sub
controllers inside
then they mount the driver seat and bolt
the top of the actuators to the back of
it
[Music]
a worker installs the seat belt along
with the spring mechanism that yanks the
belt back when you hit the brakes
they close in the sides of the main
structure with aluminum panels
next they assemble the simulator's three
petals
gas breaks and clutch and mount the
clutch mechanism to it
the pedal assembly is installed to the
base of the steering frame
[Music]
they mount the dashboard to the top of
the frame
it's made of carbon fiber and contains
the computer and audio controls
they attach the steering frame to the
main structure
[Music]
then they assemble the steering wheel
inside its base is a circuit board that
controls the buttons on the wheel and
gear shift
it's called the shift paddle
[Music]
they mount the shift paddle to the base
then flip it over to attach the wheel
next workers assemble the display frame
it holds the simulator's three monitors
in three front speakers
then they roll in the rest of the
simulator and plug the monitors and
speakers into the computer
finally the steering wheel is mounted to
the dash
it snaps in and out allowing the driver
to easily switch between
steering wheel models
the simulator is run through several
days of test drives before it ships out
amusement parks also purchase these
simulators to offer visitors a race car
driving experience
they can even link multiple simulators
together to race against each other in
virtual replicas of the world's most
famous racetracks
you